One of the things I'm most amazed by at
the moment is how the ideas and issues
that we're talking about every week here
on the Rubin report are relevant,
not just in America,
but all over the world.
The amount of email I'm getting from you
guys across the globe,
whether it's Sweden,
Australia,
Brazil,
hungrier.
Japan is actually staggering.
It really seems to me that there has
been a real awakening as to what being a
free human being is all about.
You are in charge of your own life and
if you start with this simple premise,
you can accomplish anything.
While the discourse on social media may
seem more toxic than ever,
I see a growing dynamic group of people
coming together through ideas and
conversation regardless of where they
were born or the color of their skin.
We're partnering with learn liberty this
week and our guest is Rajshree Agarwal.
She was born in India to a traditional
family only move to America where she
now teaches about capitalism at the
University of Maryland where she is the
chair and professor of entrepreneurship.
She believes that capitalism provides
maximum freedom and happiness to all
people regardless of race,
religion,
or anything else,
the ideas of freedom that one sparked in
her as a young child or the same ideas
that she's now helping further by
teaching minds of young people today.
That is what freedom is all about.
If you want to join me in spreading
these ideas of freedom and individuality
in person,
I will be joining Jordan Peterson on his
12 rules for life tour for as many dates
as I can possibly fit in.
We kicked off the tour a couple of weeks
ago at the beacon in New York City where
the energy in the room was absolutely
bananas.
I'll be traveling with Jordan to the UK
to speak in London at the Apollo
Hammersmith Theater on May 13th,
and then on May 14th,
I have the incredible honor of speaking
at the Oxford Union.
Hopefully I'll get to meet as many you
guys as possible and I also promised to
down as many points as possible.
I'm also working on an Australian tour
and hope to have some more info on that
for you guys soon.
You know,
I've mentioned on the show lately that
the endless hysteria of the left and the
politically correct craziness that we're
caught up and was eventually going to
drag me back into standup comedy and
this finally came to fruition this past
Sunday at the Irvine Improv.
The show is billed as an evening of
stand up and sit down as I did about an
hour of standup and then Bob Saget
joined me on stage for about 45 minutes
of a sit down.
It was awesome.
Meeting so many you guys out there in
the show was a huge success.
The manager of the Improv even told me
that it was the first sold out,
standing ovation.
She seen at the club in her 18 years.
We're going to announce travel dates for
upcoming standup gigs pretty soon and I
hope that you guys will join me for at
least a two drink minimum and plenty of
laughs.
And finally,
after years in the making,
we taped our interview with Dr Thomas
Soul yesterday on location at Stanford
University in San Francisco.
We flew our whole team up there and
rented a studio to make it happen.
It was truly a personal and career
highlight for me and I can't wait to
share our sit down with you next week.
Big thanks to our supporters on Patrion
who make interviews like this,
so all these announcements aside,
whether a year in the US,
India,
Oxford,
San Francisco,
or anywhere else,
we're all in this fight together.
Keep fighting for what you believe in
and I'll do the same.
We're continuing our partnership with
learn liberty today and joining me is
the root of p lamone chair and professor
of entrepreneurship at the University of
Maryland as well as the director for the
Ed Snider Center for Enterprise and
Economics.
Rajshree Agarwal.
Welcome to the Rubin report.
Thank you for having me.
Dave.
I feel we're going to have a very good
talk because we've already sort of had
the interview before we started.
We've been doing it already.
I'm looking forward to this because we
did meet once before we were at a
conference in DC that was sort of
focusing on academia and free speech and
we spent a couple of minutes talking and
what I thought was interesting.
Yeah,
I don't think you knew who I was
beforehand and that I didn't know who
you were before hand and they sort of
brought me there to talk a little bit
about how youtube plays a part in
reaching young people and technology and
all that and you were very interested in
that.
So we didn't really focus on free speech
together,
but we focused on how technology is
shifting the conversation a so just very
quickly to start,
why are you interested in how technology
is affecting the conversation related to
free speech capitalism?
The whole thing.
So I'm not interested in technology per
se,
but I'm interested in technology because
it represents the manifestation of the
human mind at work.
Ultimately,
what is technology?
Technology is better machines,
but what our machines ultimately,
whether they are fast computers or
whether they're the industrialized age
engines or whatever you call it,
right?
They are ways for us humans to make our
lives easier by using machines.
So technology ultimately is a way for
humans to communicate better,
to live better lives and to use their
mind in doing so.
So I study innovation.
I study technology because it enables us
to be the best we can be by using our
mind.
I was very proud when you walked in here
because you study innovation and
entrepreneurship and this is my garage
that we turned into a studio.
So I thought
yes,
and think about all of the creativity
that went into it,
right?
Not just by you,
but all of the thing,
all of the,
the techniques the machines had,
we're looking around.
It was someone's mind that had to come
up with it first.
So creativity,
which is at the heart of individual
enterprise is what I love.
And that's what I study.
All right?
So that's what we're going to spend most
of this hour talking about that.
Uh,
and you know,
when we do these shows with learn
liberty,
they always send me just a quick one
page bio and everybody and I really
loved years.
There was a bunch of quotes in there
that I,
that I want to quote directly to you,
um,
but
no,
that when they asked me to write that
bio,
I dish that out in about 15 minutes at
4:30
in the morning.
Oh,
look at you patting yourself on the back
saying,
well,
this was really good when you got here.
But first let's talk a little bit about
your history because you have an
interesting history.
You were born in India and you lived
there for that,
for your first 21 years.
Tell me a little bit about that.
Well,
um,
I was born to a very,
very traditional family,
Hindu family.
My father was your typical rags to
riches entrepreneur.
He embodied enterprise and he,
in fact,
I'll tell you about this one story.
I was in fifth grade and I came home so
upset because the history lesson that I
had just heard was all about how the
United Kingdom,
Britain came in and just plundered his
Golden Pico.
That was Indian.
Look at all the nasty things that they
did to us and how oppressed and
victimized we were.
And my father,
who was a very much a traditional
Orthodox Hindu at that time said,
no,
actually Britain did more good for India
than they did bad.
And it's like,
Huh,
what do you mean by that?
And he went on to talk about why before
that it's true that India was rich,
but what does rich mean?
It meant that the kings and the traders
were rich,
but then also very feudalist economy at
that time.
And of course they were also very
balconies because each of these kingdoms
were fighting with each other.
So one of the things that he talked
about is how the advent of the British,
you know,
they bought the rule of law,
they bought infrastructure,
they gave us English as a language.
You know,
often people,
my husband says,
Oh wow,
you talk better English than I do.
And it's like,
yes,
that's because I was educated in English
as well.
But at the same time that he was such a
entrepreneur in his mindset,
he was very traditionalist in his views
of how a woman should be.
And so when I was 12 years old,
he said to me,
the right and the responsibility of
finding a husband for you is mine,
don't you forget that.
And of course any woman in his family
couldn't work because that was a slap on
his face in his ability to provide for
us.
But if you think about it at 12 years
old and being told that the two biggest
decisions any individual can make for
themselves who you marry and what you
choose to work in.
And I,
and I,
and I tell you know,
I'd like to think that those two
decisions under grid,
everything that we do both at work and
they're not work life that we live.
If those are taken away from you,
what does that mean about you as an
individual?
You as a person.
So between 12 and 18,
I had to navigate that distance because
at 12 years old I was a daddy's girl.
Instead,
of course,
dad,
just please do me a favor.
Find me a husband who lives in Bombay
because I can't even bear the thought of
being in a city that's different from
you.
And at 18 I had to see for myself that I
couldn't renege on that decision,
so between 18 and 21 was really my
discovery of who I wanted to be.
And at 21 I left India,
two suitcases in my hand left everybody
that I loved,
a very generous inheritance and my
father did not speak to me for seven
years.
Wow.
I mean there's,
there's so much there of your formative
stuff that,
that leads you to where you're at right
now.
When you came home that day in fifth
grade,
you learned something in school and then
you hear something different from your
father who you obviously respected and
admired and had,
as you said,
rags to riches had provided a good life
for you guys.
How did you go back to school after
that?
I mean,
did you go back and start arguing with
teachers?
Oh,
I was always arguing with.
I was.
In fact,
I remember my science teacher saying
Rajshree,
why do you ask so many wise?
Pretty sure that's not what a science
teacher.
You're supposed to say that.
That's really fascinating.
So you picked up and left and left an
inheritance.
All of this,
you get to America.
Just tell me a little bit about that
initial experience.
So,
uh,
for me,
this was,
um,
freedom.
Uh,
it was,
you know,
I had lived in India,
especially in the generation that I was
in.
A woman didn't go or a woman did not
live by themselves,
right?
The God,
they stayed with their parents still.
They were married and then they went to
their husband's house.
So the concept of really being yourself
and having the responsibility to make
your own choices is both liberating.
But then I also realized I can't blame
my parents were my mistakes anymore.
Indeed.
Oh,
five years later I've been my mom,
or six years later when my mom came to
visit with us,
my husband said,
you know,
what is the one biggest difference that
you've seen your daughter?
And this will tell you a little bit
about my personality there too.
She says to him,
she's become very responsible.
Wow,
that's fascinating guy.
And she's uses this as evidence.
She says,
you know,
are her father used to give her a very
generous allowance,
but we were,
we would marvel at the fact that this
kid would go through this allowance
within 10 or 12 days and then she'd say,
I'd like more and then her father would
sometimes give it and sometimes there's
no,
that's all you're going to get.
So then come to me or she'd come to her
brother or I started to Taylor because I
often said I owned my own bread and
butter,
but my father provided we met with the
jam.
Right.
But,
uh,
one of the things that she said was,
now she looks at me and she's realized
is just how responsible that become.
That where before money would just flow
off of my fingers and I wouldn't give it
a second thought.
I had become so much more responsible in
my thinking and I think she was talking
a lot more about than just money in
India.
I was rebelling because I was fighting
against something.
I came to the United States.
I didn't have to fight against anything.
So I had to figure out who I was.
And what I really wanted to be and it
allowed me to thrive.
So you mentioned you didn't talk to your
father for seven years after that.
It had the reconciliation it or was it a
reconciliation?
Reconciliation?
In fact,
one of the things that I really,
really treasure is,
um,
you know,
for the,
I was a daddy's girl and I did want his
approval and after I got my phd,
I remember this one conversation that I
had with him where I was the prodigal
daughter.
He was just finally talking to me again.
I think he'd given up on the fact that I
would be this person that would
ultimately come home with my tail
between my legs and say,
you know,
you were right.
I was wrong.
He just completely given up on that.
And so he was listening to me and of
course I was trying to impress him.
So I was talking to him about all of
these achievements as a young assistant
professor.
I had received a couple of awards.
I was getting to go to these prestigious
conferences and he's listening,
but there's silence on his side.
And the more I'm talking,
the more he silent and then finally I
just gave up.
I had nothing more to brag about or talk
about and I wasn't getting the.
I'm so proud of you from him.
And so there was this uncomfortable
silence after which he says it's a
phrase in Hindi which roughly translated
says if a peacock dances in a forest who
sees.
So who cares?
And his point to me was,
you can be all of the peacock,
you are,
but if you're not next to me,
it doesn't mean anything.
So that was the harshness that we
started off with,
even in the reconciliation.
But my last visit with him paradoxically
was when I was asked to give a keynote
in India.
This was immediately after India's
liberalization.
It was trying as an economy that we now
know it to be.
And so I was asked to give a keynote at
an academic conference on
entrepreneurship and economic growth.
And so on my way to this conference,
I stopped by and 10 years after I had
done my phd,
I'm finally talking to my father about
my research and connecting it to his own
entrepreneurial spirit and him being a
serial entrepreneur and I can finally
see the pride in his eyes.
I got there and then add the keynote at
the end of this thing.
When you go to India,
you realize that when you give a speech,
they will give you a present.
So in front of about 500 people,
they give me this president that I
opened and believe it or not,
it's a peacock.
Seems fitting seems there's so much
there and it's so obvious hearing this
story,
how it led to all of the things that
you're teaching about now and care about
the concept between the battle between
sort of traditionalism and then the
entrepreneurial spirit is really a
fascinating one because he obviously had
that.
Yes,
he built something for himself,
built a good life,
and then still wanted that piece of sort
of the old world.
And I think we all kind of struggle with
that in a way.
Maybe that's what the struggle of
western civilization is and stuff.
I actually think that this relates to
often the need to think and integrate
one psychological growth with one's
growth in the material and in the
Richard Israel.
So one of the things that I think my
father was as a paradox unfortunately,
and I think that caused him as well as
me,
so much of this angsty between us,
is that at the same time that he applied
his intellect into the economic realm,
he psychologically did not necessarily
realize that,
you know,
part of the reason he was successful is
because he was able to make his own
decisions,
which also meant the freedom to make
your own mistakes and learn from your
mistakes.
So why he allowed that there as far as
family was concerned.
There was this very protectionist,
I need to take care of you,
but that I'm realizing this as a parent
is not very conducive to your children's
growth because what you really need to
give them are the tools to make their
own decisions as opposed to telling
them,
you know,
this is the way you should do it.
Yeah.
And ironically,
had you not broken away and been free,
although,
although he may have been very pleased
with your life and who knows what your
life would be and maybe you maybe you
would be happy in some ways it wouldn't
have led you to all this,
so you had to directly have to do that.
So.
So one more thing about India before we
move on to everything else that you're
doing.
A I told you right before we started
that I can a ton of fan mail from India.
I think there's some really interesting
political things happening right there
that seemed to be driving people to
watching shows like this.
Just give me one thing that we should
know about India right now that maybe we
don't know as Americans,
which I think is probably probably
everything because India never comes up
in the new Israeli.
So.
So I can talk about India right now a
little less than I can talk about the
India that I grew up in and why growing
in India actually fostered my
entrepreneurial spirit.
Okay.
So we can do it a little bit of a little
bit of that.
Right.
And I think that that is one of the
aspects.
It's definitely selection at play,
but I do think that across every culture
people,
individuals are born Tabula Rasa,
some cultures are much more conducive to
having the entrepreneurial spirit bloom
and as a result you see people go so
much farther.
But there are other cultures and other
cultures stifle it.
But as individuals,
I think we all have the same proclivity
to be the persons that we can be.
But one of the things that I always
credited in my education in India is the
focus on thinking and critical thinking
and intellectual ism.
So the concept of a nerd growing up for
me was unheard off because the,
the coolest kids were also the ones that
participated in science and elocution
debates.
You know,
I was always at the forefront.
I wasn't so much of a sportsperson
right.
But I was very much in debates in
elocution competitions and science
competitions and so on.
And that was cool.
That wasn't considered rural United
States.
Right.
So the concept that there's a node and a
node is socially awkward,
which was unheard of for me.
I'll give you another example.
You know,
my brother was the one that first talked
to me about Iran and of course in that
journey that I was telling you about
where I had to find my own identity
reading atlas shrugged was really the
pillar of strength and helped me
identify my own sense of life.
But the way I read atlas shrugged you'd
find very funny is I'm in colleges in
India.
If you're a guy and you want to impress
a chick,
you carry,
at least in my time,
a paperback novel of Atlas shrugged in
your back pocket because that means if
you're intellectually you're thinking
now.
I was also said it was also sad.
That's so fascinating to me.
Right?
And,
and,
and it's also said,
well,
if you're young,
then you believe in these views,
but then you grow up and you grow over
it.
I had never grown over it.
I think that that aspect of the mind,
uh,
the ability to think through decisions
is one that I will credit the Indian
culture and my father for endowing in
me.
Yeah.
Well you'll be happy to know,
as I mentioned to you before that you
know,
I was at the students for liberty
conference and I met several students
from India who were there that are
involved with Iran,
instituted in that consider themselves
objective isn't all that and it seems
that some of those ideas at least are
thriving there.
So that brings it into the modern day.
Okay.
So as I mentioned,
I really loved your bio and they were a
couple of great quotes in there.
So I want to read one directly to you.
You said my passion is upward mobility
integrated across intellectual,
psychological and economic realms.
I cared deeply about growth.
Achievement for me is measured not by
the level you have attained as much as
the road you have traveled.
For me,
the journey is the destination and I
cared deeply about integrity as in the
whole of a person rather than the
individual part.
And I thought there's obviously a lot
there,
but it seems to me that this is sort of
what we're missing these days.
We've got people that are just screaming
at each other all the time that
everyone's pretending they're an expert
in everything.
Nobody sort of listening.
Um,
you know,
I've been traveling with Jordan Peterson
allowed who's talking so much about what
I think is such simple stuff in a
certain way,
although he's quite brilliant at it.
You were talking about personal
responsibility and being a full person.
And I thought that that was really what
you were getting to.
Yes.
So,
um,
what's the question?
So the question is,
well,
I guess I sort of know why you came to
believe this,
but we seem to have a real lack of an
ability to be a full integral part
these days.
I think in part it really relates to
this entrepreneurial mindset and a
growth mindset.
And for me personally,
that is,
um,
a perspective that is in some sense,
selfish.
Let me explain by what I mean by that.
And I mean selfish in a very positive
way here.
Oh,
I am right now in endowed professor.
I'll just give you an example of it,
right,
and I get to mentor a lot of young minds
and many of them come to my office,
particularly Phd Students,
uh,
with this mindset of I know so much it
is true,
I know a lot,
but think about the interaction between
a student and a professor where if the
professor says,
I know everything,
you're my student and you're going to
learn from me.
It's a one way street.
It's the student benefiting from the
professor with that mindset.
But how has the professor benefiting
from it?
Where is my learning?
Where is my growth?
So in this conversation,
one of the ways that I approach this
relationship is I see you have to start
this conversation thinking of each other
as intellectual equals.
I may know more than you,
but especially in the realm of research
which is creating new knowledge.
I need you to have an questioning mind
because what happens if you're saying
something that I want to challenge,
and after all in academia,
we are in the marketplace for ideas.
If I challenge you and your mind
immediately shuts down because you say,
oh,
Rajshree said this,
she's the expert professor.
She knows everything and you're not
going to challenge me,
then you're not allowing yourself to
learn.
But more importantly,
if I know that about you,
I'm going to shut myself down and I am
going to send so myself from expressing
my ideas because I want your mind to be
open.
So now we both lose.
And the bold silenced ourselves.
So this is just one example of where I
think that this,
um,
this focus on growth and on learning is
actually very liberating.
And in that sense,
very selfish for me because now like
with them is a two way street.
I'm not just teaching,
I'm also learning how do you get
over the concept that selfishness is
somehow evil?
That I think a lot of people believe
this inherently.
You say,
well,
I'm selfish,
or they think,
well,
you're evil.
So this actually relates to one of this
point about the lack of integration or
this,
uh,
thinking about either or.
So the common concept of selfishness is
as in,
well,
you're only thinking about yourself and
not thinking about the other.
Why,
why does it have to be an eternal?
Why cannot it be a wind when trade,
which is fundamentally recognizing your
dignity,
my dignity,
your identity,
my identity and knowledge that should
we,
you know,
right now you and I are talking,
why are we sitting here and having this
conversation other than the fact,
of course that,
uh,
you know,
we're,
we're passionate about these ideas and
we find that our time together is
meaningfully well spent.
So much enjoyment out of this
conversation is not at your expense.
Neither is what your gaining outfitted
my expense.
In fact,
we're creating value together.
But you brought it into this room
because that.
That's exactly right for me at least.
It's like in a way I'm doing something
selfish in that.
I'm doing my show.
I'm bringing a guest on that will
hopefully get people to watch.
Right?
And you're here because you want your
ideas to spread.
The people that are watching this
hopefully are getting something out of
it for themselves.
I mean,
that's what people really need to
understand that that's what's integral
about this.
It doesn't mean we're taking from you.
It actually means that we're giving to
ourselves and something.
Yes.
And so for me,
this notion that selfishness means this
brute that is just going to ride
roughshod over everybody else's rights
and responsibility fundamentally does
not get to this idea that each of us
have our right to live our lives the way
we see best and you know,
take the consequences,
good or bad,
all our decisions.
How much of this do you think is about
just whether people view humans
fundamentally as good or evil?
So if you fundamentally think people are
evil and you say to someone,
be selfish,
well then it is that they're going to
run roughshod over everybody and destroy
the environment and steal money and kill
people and all that versus if you
believe people are fundamentally good or
at least neutral than if they do
something for themselves,
it will potentially be
for themselves.
Me,
the only evil is really the use of force
to,
um,
throttle somebody else.
You can do what you want to do.
So long as you're not infringing on
other people's rights and
responsibilities and their ability to
live their life the way they do and
indeed in a civil society that is the
fundamental respect that we all each
other that I live my life the best way
that I think is done,
but I'm not going to impose my views on
you.
I may have a conversation with you about
my views and you're free to agree or
disagree with my views and free to agree
or to interact or not with me,
but I can't force my views and my
beliefs on you and neither should you
force.
I mean that's fundamentally the
conversation between my father and I
didn't think about it,
right.
It is that we were both very aligned in
our views 80 percent of the time,
but the 20 percent where he thought that
as a father he had the right to tell me
what I should do as opposed to be the
facilitator and guide an advisor to my
decisions.
That is the fundamental disconnect.
Do you think we spend too much time on
that 20 percent or you know,
I think I heard Barry Weiss on real time
called the narcissism of small
differences where we,
we can agree on almost everything
philosophically and then we find
something.
Yes.
And then that is what we focus on our
level
and it really depends upon,
is that something in a hierarchy of your
values,
a fundamental issue that you do need to
disagree on or is that something in the
hierarchy of your values and your
beliefs?
Something that is not as critical to the
conversation that we're having.
So I prefer a indeed.
I am a big believer in win-win outcomes.
Um,
I don't,
you know,
my husband is my best friend.
I love him.
The last thing I would want is for him
to say Rajshree,
I'm with you.
Not because it gives me any selfish joy,
not because I get any pleasure.
I take pity on you.
I feel sorry for you.
And that's why my life's objective is to
take care of you.
Do you want a relationship?
I walk out the door,
I'd say,
if I am not giving you personal
satisfaction and joy in being with me,
if I'm not your best friend,
just like your mind,
then this relationship is not a win win
and I don't want to be either an object
of charity or a or pity or A.
I don't want you to feel like you're
obligated,
so I want to backup to say you said a
few minutes ago about the way that you
teach and that exchange between
professor and student where it's sort of
you're trying to look at each other as
equals.
I might learn something from them and
they might learn something from me.
So.
So two parts of that.
First all,
how often do you find that you actually
learned something?
Oh,
every time.
Indeed.
Last year,
University of Maryland honored me with a
distinguished scholar teacher award and
one of my first slides was about exactly
that.
The debt that I owe to my advisor who
incidentally gave me away when Robin and
I got married.
I remember my father wasn't talking to
me.
My advisor was my second father and so I
learned a lot from him and I have
benefited from that learning off a
mentor advisor relationship,
but I have benefited equally from paying
it forward so every one of my phd
students I can pinpoint to you exactly
what ideas they helped me learn which
empirical context and innovative
industries I went into along with them
and how my own scholarship has
fundamentally benefited and even change
trajectories because of my phd students.
So the second part of that then would be
do you think that is a real rarity on
college campuses these days that that
professors are willing to learn from
students because when I go to colleges,
which I'm doing all the time now,
one of the things I hear most is that
students are actually afraid to
challenge their professors because they
think it's going to hurt their grades
and that generally just generally
speaking,
this seems to come from more leftist
professors that if you challenge them on
intersectionality or or any of that,
that people actually think their grades
will suffer.
Do you think that that's
a broad problem in academia?
It is.
Unfortunately,
I,
you know,
there is this part of me in my soul that
says that just cannot be true.
Please let this not be true because the
fundamental identity,
often academic should be one which is
focused on learning and focused on ideas
and indeed I would say that one requires
a confidence and a self esteem and to be
comfortable with being challenged and so
often I do have several colleagues that
I worry about in as much as they don't
make good advisors and part of the
reason they don't make good advisors is
not because they are not experts in
their sphere,
but precisely because they cannot stand
being challenged by their students and
in my opinion,
that's a lose lose.
Not only are you stymieing the students'
growth,
you signing your own growth.
Yeah.
So when you hear people talking about
the free speech issues on college
campuses and at the conference that we
were at,
I mean there were literally hundreds of
professors there to talk about how do we
defend free speech.
That was the whole purpose of it.
Do you sense that something has shifted
in the last couple of years?
Does it seem worse?
I give you my own personal story.
About three years,
two years ago,
I ended up writing an op Ed in the
Washington Post on confessions of a
silenced professor.
Now you've heard me these last 15,
20 minutes.
Anyone that knows me says Rajshree you
silence.
Give me a break.
Easily silenced.
Exactly.
And indeed part of the team off that
ipad was a very important self
realization that I had.
And that was a,
that I was now starting to think,
do I really want to take this on?
And it was a colleague of mine who we
were just having a conversation about
something that had happened at a
conference,
uh,
and she said to me and I was like,
you know,
I'm wondering,
should I weigh in on this or should I
just let it go?
And the point is not what the issue was.
The point is that I even asked that
question,
which is what this colleague said to me,
she says,
Rajshree,
when did you become so afraid of
speaking your mind?
And that really hit me in my gut,
if you will.
It's like,
when did I start thinking if I do this,
what's going to be the fallout within
the academic circles?
Should I repress myself?
And that's when I realized that the
spiral of silence where we ended up.
So,
you know,
you can talk about censorship.
I actually think at the University of
Maryland,
I am in a great university president on
down.
We have a investment and a dedication to
words,
freedom of speech,
and thinking about the academia as a
marketplace for ideas.
So great to hear it.
I,
I mean,
I just,
before I came here,
I had a phenomenal conversation with the
president,
uh,
regarding an event where we're worried
about whether or not there is going to
be some backlash because of some of the
people I've been bringing in in a
debate.
But for us it's very important to have
that reasoned and respectful discourse.
But for me it was,
you know,
people from the outside can tell you
whatever they want.
But when you start to silence yourself,
that's when you silence your mind.
That's when you don't let your
innovative creativity.
What is freedom of speech about it is
not in the freedom to agree.
It's the freedom to disagree,
but doing so in a manner,
and again,
coming back to this use of force,
right?
I can say what I want.
I am not.
You know,
I,
I in college campuses these days,
one of the things that they say is,
well,
words can hurt.
You know,
I was in a convent and the teachers used
to say,
sticks and stones can break my bones,
but words don't hurt me.
Right?
And yes,
words do have power.
I'm not denying that for sure.
Several of the things that father said
to me psychologically will very wounding
and I had to work through that.
So I'm not denying the fact that words
in the psychological and intellectual
ram are very powerful,
but the point is,
is a fundamental difference between
words and coercion.
As in now I am forcing you to think
otherwise because words are
fundamentally our minds thinking and
then communicating with each other.
We've had a long sort of slippery road
on this,
right?
Where people are starting to think that
words mean action or that you have some
sort of right to not be offended or a
right to comfort.
I mean you just simply don't have.
I think actually,
oh,
it's the converse is true.
You need to be courageous to look at
something and say,
this doesn't accord with my beliefs,
so you know,
they.
Let me use a different analogy out here.
People often talk about open versus
closed mine.
I actually think neither of those
concepts make sense because what is a
closed mine that is the professor that
you and I were just talking about who
says,
I'm right?
How dare you challenge me?
I've made up my decision already.
Right?
But an open mind is someone that's just
sitting on the fence,
not willing to take any kind of a
committed stand.
In fact,
I would prefer a close mind to an open
mind in that way.
Right?
But what I really care about is an
active mine that I have some opinions,
some beliefs,
and they're based on the prior thinking
that I have done,
but I'm not omniscient.
I'm not infallible.
I could have made mistakes in my
thinking,
so having an active mind allows me,
the,
gives me the permission to say I do have
these thoughts and beliefs,
but if someone provides me with
compelling evidence and compelling logic
that would make me change my thinking,
then it isn't my best interests to do
so.
You know,
it's funny.
I find I often,
I sit across brilliant people all the
time and every now and again someone
dropped something that I think,
wow,
that's what I've been trying to get to
active mind.
I mean I'm going to start using that
phrase because that's right.
You don't just want an open mind of,
of endless nothing actually.
And you don't want to close my but an
active mind.
Keep.
Keep working.
Yeah.
So I want to ask you one other thing on
it.
So then I really want to focus on all
this stuff that you're teaching for the
whole second half.
What do you think the actual solution is
related to this?
So if a,
if a professor like you has this sudden
need or fear of self censoring and I
get.
It's pretty obvious to me how open and
courageous you are inherently.
Um,
what do you think the solution is?
And when we were at this conference,
a lot of the professors were saying this
has to come from the donors because the
administrators at the schools cannot be
brave enough if they think that their
jobs are on the line all the time.
But that the one way to do it is that if
the donors are slowly turning off the
money to professors that won't defend
free speech or administrators who won't
back the professors who do that.
That might be though
the chain.
Does that make sense to you?
Yes,
and I disagree with it,
but let me explain to you why I disagree
with it.
Oh,
you cannot.
So this comes back to the first question
you asked me.
Why do I focus on integrity and why do I
think about economics,
which is money and donors along with
psychological and intellectual growth.
For me,
you cannot have one without the other.
These are pieces of an entire,
uh,
that,
that fit together to make an integrated
whole within academia.
One always has to worry about the fact
that you've got all of these pressures,
pressures for conformity,
pressures for funding and resources that
are coming in there would you really
care about and which you cannot renege
if you are an intellectual entrepreneur,
which is truly what being in academia is
all about.
Being an intellectual entrepreneur is
your unwavering focus on knowledge,
creating knowledge,
and if I,
if I may say so,
untruth
resources,
just like any venture capitalist,
so this intellectual entrepreneur,
maybe a good analogy,
actually venture capitalists provide you
with the financial resources,
but they are complimentary resource
providers.
They cannot tell you which direction
should you go,
nor should they right?
If you don't have that creative mindset,
that intellectual horsepower,
if you're not courageous enough to go
for that,
then any kind of pressure from the
venture capitalists is not going to help
nor are any kind of pivots and
directions and so on.
So the way I look at it is I do not and
will not ever change my research based
on what donors may or may not give.
On the contrary,
I will look for aligned to donors
because you cannot put the cart before
the horse.
You cannot put your purpose behind the
money or the success metrics of your
purpose.
Your purpose has to drive all of the
other resources that you garner.
So if an administrator lacks courage,
that's on the administrator first and
foremost.
If an academic lacks courage of
conviction,
that's on them.
You can have complimentary people
aligned with you kind of helping you
along the way,
but they cannot substitute for that
fundamental drive that you need to have.
All right?
So everything that we spent the first 30
some odd minutes talking about,
it sort of leads to academic integrity.
It sounds like to me that these,
that we need not only the students to
have some integrity,
but the administrators,
that professors,
everything else,
everyone at the university altogether.
Do you think that's a fair?
That's what I expect you to do?
Absolutely.
In fact,
um,
I think that we often confuse the terms
academic freedom and academic integrity.
Would we really care about is academic
integrity first and foremost,
and academic integrity really means that
I'm not going to sell my soul or my
ideas based on the highest bidder.
I believe that,
you know,
and this is again the search for truth
that requires integrity and then of
course I have the freedom to collaborate
with people,
including donors on areas where we find
mutually beneficial relationships and
when,
when trade.
Yeah.
So one of the things that you talked
about,
and I referenced it earlier in one of
these quotes are that you really focused
on is upward mobility.
Yes.
And it,
I think it's particularly interesting
right now because if you listen to some
of our political leaders,
it seems like we've sort of completely
lost the ability that we were separated
by class and all that.
You come from a place where upward
mobility was very hard.
Um,
it's gotten less hard as they've
embraced as India's embrace capitalism
first.
I guess in the most broad sense,
tell me why you think upward mobility is
so important,
but more importantly,
what's the state of it in America right
now?
So I actually think that we in the
United States,
focus on upward mobility as if this was
a major problem in the US.
Other countries are becoming more market
oriented than the United States.
The United States still stands as the
one place where you really,
really have the ability to be upwardly
mobile and I think that is the greatest
asset that the United States still have.
And I'm very proud to call this country
my country of choice.
So let,
let's sit in that idea for a second
because I totally agree with it and it
seems to me that all of the people who
say that's not true are missing,
that are laws here allow you to do
whatever you want with your life.
It doesn't mean that you are going to do
it.
It doesn't mean that it's going to be
handed to you,
but as you just said,
as an immigrant that came here,
that is become tremendously successful.
You're living proof that you can do it.
Absolutely.
And that still holds.
In fact,
in some ways I think we so take these
laws for granted that we don't know what
the rest of the world is out there,
so my daughters have grown up and been
born in the United States,
but I think that their biggest learning
moments come when they leave the country
and see things even in India today as
they as it exists,
these see the disparities of the things
that they can take for granted were
Susan India,
but you still have to fight with the
corruption.
You still have to fight with these
status aspects.
The United States is very status free
relative to most other countries,
including India and there's a dignity to
human labor here that is often missing
in many other cultures.
That is the aspect that I care about
when I care about upward mobility and
you know what?
Let's be honest.
Out here I did not have the kind of
privileges that my daughters too.
I could've been more on the fact that,
you know,
I came from a country or from a
traditional family values that I had to
have the family tradition.
There was such that I had to have this
fight that for sure defined me
positively,
but also class some psychological scars
and of course my hope is that my
daughters don't go through that and I
could go there and say,
you know,
of the level at which they're starting
off is so much higher than the level I'm
starting off and are they privileged and
look at all that I didn't have or I can
focus their minds and their ideas and
you know,
you may start here,
but the definition of your achievement
is not your level,
but where you end,
you find it fascinating that people are
constantly attacking that they are.
They attack people that have a little
bit more to start with,
which is the whole point of life.
You want your children to have more.
The only way that it would be fair it is
not because I can be raised to their
level.
The only way to do it is to bring them
down to the level that I started.
And is that fair?
Right.
And so again,
by focusing on the level that one starts
with as a measure,
often individually achievement,
I think is not necessarily focusing on
their individual effort and a lot of
people.
Um,
even in India,
um,
you know,
as I said to you,
my father went from rags to riches and
there were a lot of people that,
that were my friends.
Then we're quite rich and they had a
very entitlement mentality.
I don't think that they're any happier
than I was even when I was poorer.
So this comes back to the point that
you,
the quote that you had,
I can just measure a person's success by
their economic riches.
You also happiness,
which is what I care about,
is a state of mind.
It's a state of consciousness that has
to be earned.
Self esteem then combined with the sense
of I'm a materially at a place that I'm
comfortable or rich,
but more than that,
psychologically and intellectually,
I feel like I've made something of
myself.
I think that is something that is so
much more inspiring to go after money.
And Snyder used to say money is the
reward.
Not The reason,
and I completely agree with that.
Yeah,
it's so interesting because I've been
thinking about this a lot lately because
obviously the show is kind of catching
fire and I'm doing okay financially and
we're building something good and I'm
traveling a lot.
People say Nice things to me all the
time and I've been thinking about that
and people keep saying,
well,
you're going to get some big offer from
one of these networks or something.
And it's like,
I hope I do too,
but I love this.
Like I'm actually happy now,
like I'm doing what I think I'm supposed
to be doing and I don't know where that
road goes,
but looking at everything holistically,
it's not just about money,
it's about doing something that gives
you value at all that uh,
but we,
we seem not to focus enough.
But that's the point,
right?
I get so much joy.
So again,
to that quote that you were talking
about,
for me,
the journey is the destination.
You know,
whether I would,
I feel younger today than I did when I
was 20 years old.
And what's the big difference?
I feel like I have earned the self
esteem,
not recognition outside because people
you know and you know this,
you need a lot of people and they come
to you and say,
Hey Dave,
you're so great,
but who is saying your great makes a big
difference to you hearing whether you
see what I mean.
So there has to be a sense of do I
believe that your saying I'm great for
the reasons that I value and if that is
there,
then I will take external adulation as a
positive.
If not,
it's hollow.
It's empty.
So self esteem is truly what one should
be striving for.
Yeah.
Do you think at some level capitalism
and maybe the western world in a wider
sense is suffering from success at the
moment that it almost seems like because
we've been so successful,
we're now going to that place that we
mentioned earlier where we're just
fighting over little differences were
then.
There's a lot of people right now.
I mean if you talk about socialism on
college campuses,
you'll,
you'll sell out the room,
you know,
and if you talk about.
Fortunately,
I find when I go and I mostly talked to
libertarian or capitalist or whatever
groups,
you know,
we're,
we're doing quite well as well,
but that the ideas that are completely
contrary to everything you've just said
seemed to be gaining some momentum,
so I don't think they're victims of our
success.
I think we're victims of the fact that
we have never really sat down and
thought seriously about the reasons for
our success and by eschewing that
intellectual thought and ideas that
under underpin our success,
we have actually sold our success.
Sure.
How should we have done that?
Do you mean on that?
Our politicians should have talked about
it more or you mean more in academia?
I think it starts from k through 12
education.
Actually.
I think that we have taken this concept,
uh,
we have short our mind in k through 12
education all the way through college
and this comes back to your example of
the faculty advisor that does not want
to be challenged by their students.
When you have that mentality as a
teacher,
whether it's in k through 12 or as a
professor in academia where I know what
is best and I am going to tell you what
it is as opposed to facilitate your
learning process,
we are not training our students how to
think anymore.
We're not giving them the ability to
learn in the manner that they do.
I'll give you another example.
Memorization caught off as a huge
negative today,
but you know,
um,
Sir Anthony Leggett who wasn't about
law.
It was a Nobel laureate and a professor
at Illinois,
which is where I was give this inspiring
speech to middle schoolers one day.
And the theme of it was,
the more you know,
the more you know what you don't know.
Knowledge is a building on process.
You have to learn first to then learn
what you need to learn again.
And so fostering that spirit in students
will then allow you to go back to first
principles.
So it's not about being an expert on any
area,
but it's about any area that you choose
to go in there.
Don't just look at the outcomes.
Don't just get the success factors and
then try to emulate the symptoms if you
will,
or the the,
the things that accompany success go
down to the very fundamental levels of
what are the ideas and what are the
first principles that enable success to
begin with.
It's interesting because this seems to
be a place where maybe technology has
harmed us because it's like instead of
having a holistic and integral view of
really knowing what you're talking
about,
well,
what do we do?
We Google it,
so maybe you'll get there,
right?
Maybe you'll get there with Google,
but you,
but you'll get just a quick answer
instead of going to the root of what you
mean.
Where I'd say,
again,
technology is a tool.
It does not absolve us of our
responsibility on how we use the tool.
I'm actually a huge fan of Google.
Google scholar has made my life so much
easier.
I remember being a doctoral student and
having to go through Lockwood,
Lockwood Library in six feet of snow in
Buffalo.
Better,
right.
If I wanted an answer to a question now,
google scholar allows me to do it in
seconds.
Microfiche is
exactly and I had to work with
microfiche to do my data gathering,
but,
but the point out here is I can use
google scholar to get just an amazing
amount of knowledge at my fingertips.
How great is that?
I mean,
I am so thankful to technology to do
that,
but that does not absolve me of the of
saying your is all of the pieces of
information.
In fact,
I would say this age of information
technology,
the need of the mind to have judgment
and to discern across all of these
pieces of information is at an all time
high.
Yeah,
so obviously you teach and you talk
about entrepreneurial spirit and
entrepreneurship.
One of the things that I think is
fascinating related to technology right
now is that Peter Teal is leaving
silicon valley because he feels that
collectivism leftism,
cultural Marxism,
maybe you have some other phrases for
whatever that is,
has sort of crushed the ability to think
so that there isn't the creativity
coming out of silicon valley that there
used to be,
which is why we don't have that many new
apps anymore.
We don't have that many new breaking
technologies and he is a capitalist and
he's ironically moving to la to become
freer,
which is sort of where people don't
think of us as a capitalist haven here
in California and La specifically.
Do you find that fascinating that that
silicon valley seems to lean so far left
and yet it's supposed to be the place of
innovation?
Now that you're saying that,
I just made a connection that I never
thought of.
My father represents exactly that.
If you think about it,
right?
He was very free market oriented as it
came to the economic realm and being
entrepreneurial in terms of creating new
products and services and economic
riches,
but when it came time to thinking he was
very traditionalist and I think that
that bifurcation,
this mindbody dichotomy,
if you will,
is what's plaguing a lot of people right
now.
So I am not an expert on silicon valley.
I have noticed of course that a lot of
people,
so facebook,
I just.
I just saw mark Zuckerberg say something
to the effect of you should have
economic regulation and social media.
It's like why you were successful is
because you did not have any barriers to
entry.
The best way to keep them monopoly is to
have government regulation because
again,
that's the use of force,
right?
If I cannot go into an industry because
there is prohibition,
so think about Uber and Uber had to deal
with in the taxi cab industry.
Think about when airlines was not what
we know it because there were just that
regulated carriers,
right?
That's someone that monopoly and the
best way for an entrepreneur who has
achieved success,
but now no longer wants to continue to
own their success is to say,
let me create barriers to entry through
government regulation so I can be
protected by any entrepreneur such as
those days ago,
right.
To then come and infringe on what I
have.
It's almost as if he's trying to protect
what he has.
I think maybe the thing,
you know,
it's so funny also how these things
change because you know,
15 years ago before uber,
when I lived in New York City,
basically my whole adult life and people
would complain relentlessly about the
cabs.
They're all broken down and the drivers
are in friendly.
They don't pick you up if you're a
certain color,
et Cetera,
et cetera.
Then Uber comes around,
fixes a lot of these problems by
ingenuity and now people are saying,
you see what they did,
they put the cabs out of business.
The same people who were upset
first in Boston.
It's even worse in Boston,
every uber or lyft ride has to be,
has to pay five cents of a surcharge and
every,
you know,
a fraction of that.
I don't remember whether it's two cents
or three cents,
but you know,
it adds up and millions of right goals
to the taxi cab industry.
That's the industry that's actually
being replaced by doing a much better
service.
Yes,
yes,
exactly.
So that just.
So then is there a flaw in capitalism
there somehow because that there's
probably some cronyism that's allowing
the politicians to write these
ridiculous
is not about markets.
Cronyism is about state isn't cronyism
is not capitalism at work.
It is government regulation at work and
this comes back to,
you know,
Dave,
you're successful.
I take pride in watching your videos,
somebody because I enjoy it,
but I'm sure is a bit of envy to about,
Gee,
I wish I could be as eloquent as David
and as the 500,000
people that watched the day Reuben show,
you know,
wow,
wouldn't I love to have that kind of an
impact?
Now that's envy on my part.
There are two things I could do,
it can either be a positive driver of my
energies,
I could say I want what Dave does has,
but I don't have,
and that can put me on a growth mindset,
entrepreneurial mindset.
What is it that I need to do in order to
achieve those success factors?
Going back to those principles,
what are the reasons behind Dave success
and what can I do to emulate or do
differently than dave or I can say,
no,
I want what Dave has,
but I don't need to own it.
I don't need to do that.
So let me get the government to take
some of what Dave has some of Dave's
sponsorship,
right?
And that's what income inequality and
redistribution is all about.
I'm taking some of your viewership and
I'm going to be forcing those people to
now listen to me.
So that's where we're using government
force.
Whether it's income redistribution or
any kind of yardstick of value where
we're redistributing,
we're saying we're going to take it from
you and that actually negates your
viewers rights.
Right?
Because now if I have the government
saying that,
then some of them would be forced to not
watch you,
but watch me on the other hand,
this jealousy,
by the way,
the difference between envy and
jealousy.
One of my colleagues just told me
recently and we is when I want something
I don't have jealousy,
is when I want to keep something that I
have,
but I'm being threatened against,
right?
Again,
positive or negative.
If I feel jealousy because I feel
threatened about what I'm about to lose,
I can go ahead and say what is it that I
need to do in order to keep it?
Or I can create barriers and say you can
have it through the use of force.
The same principles.
I work at cronyism at both sides of the
yardstick.
So when we talk about relative poverty
in the United States as an income
inequality,
by the way coming from India,
I know what true poverty is.
We in the United States,
the minimum level of poverty here is so
much better than the rest of the world.
So if we care,
again,
it's about inbeat.
These rich people have what I don't have
and I should get them,
or on the rich end of the spectrum,
I have this as a welder.
I'm a person regardless of whether I got
it out of an inheritance or because of
prior entrepreneurial thinking,
it's being threatened,
but I want to keep it for myself.
So the best way for me to do that is to
lobby the government and erect barriers
to entry on both sides.
The use of governmental regulation to
respond to envy and jealousy is a
negative,
not a positive driver of economic
growth.
So where do you,
where do you draw the line or where is
the starting point then of what
government is supposed to do?
A government has a legal monopoly on
force as it should because you and I in
a civil society cannot focus our mind,
our effort on creating value if we're
always going to worry about somebody
looting or taking things away from us.
Right?
So I am not an anarchist.
I believe in governments.
I believe in the rule of law.
I believe in the protection.
So there are basic functions of the
government that absolutely are essential
beyond that keep the economy away from
the realm of the government because the
government's only ability to do
something is to say you and your best
judgment.
I think you should go a I am telling you
you need to go be,
you're forcing the mind to not think or
act on their best judgment.
Yeah.
So it's interesting in the,
in the case of Uber and what you were
describing in Boston and the penny's
going back to the,
to the cabbies who have nothing to do
with it.
That actually is because of regulation
and that the,
and the only way to that and let new
businesses thrive is let them thrive.
Let me just let,
just let them,
let them know.
Um,
all right.
So there's a couple more things that I
want to do with you and you had a four
questions about personal leadership.
Then you ask a lot of your students and
I thought that these were really great
at it and it really,
this I think sort of puts a nice bow on
everything that we've talked about here.
So the first one is what is your
purpose?
Kids must be kids.
Students must be.
They must look at you Kinda Kinda
curiously when you asked it that one
because that's a.
that's a big.
So that means spend two seconds just
telling you about why I came up with
this framework.
Yeah.
I'm a strategy and entrepreneurship
professor and I was asked to teach in a
program which was largely minority,
high school student based and I was
asked to give a lecture on strategic
management and strategic management is
typically the realm of ceos.
How can highschoolers identify and
associate with questions that a CEO has
to deal with.
That was the big challenge that I had.
How am I supposed to talk to them about
at that time with Steve Jobs is doing
for apple even though they recognize
apple and make it real to them and I
realize I didn't need to do that.
I could say to them especially because
they're at the cusp of identifying who
they are and creating their identity.
You're the CEO of [inaudible]
incorporated.
Are you thinking like a ceo?
What are the four fundamental questions
that a CEO should ask and are you asking
those questions of yourself?
And it begins with the first one is what
is your purpose?
The second is,
what does success look like?
The third is,
what's my value proposition given that
that's my purpose and that's what
success looks like.
And then finally in this stumps a lot of
people with whom should I trade?
So these four questions I think are the
essence of any entrepreneurial
individual or any entrepreneurial
organization.
How often when you ask these students
these questions,
did they have some good answers?
Oh my gosh,
these are tough.
I mean these ones,
your purpose,
these are the questions of all time,
right?
You're asking them in the framework of
business and entrepreneurship.
Actually,
so I,
I,
I'm actually agnostic about whether they
want to define what is your purpose as
it relates to their career or as it
relates to their life,
but the answers that I provide them in
the context of thinking and you wouldn't
be amazed as to how much this resonates
all the way from beginning high
schoolers,
including my own daughter who was forced
to take this class with me to executives
in my executive Mba.
So what is your purpose really requires
people to think about what problems do I
want to solve that are meaningful to me.
So it again comes to making world a
better place to live by doing something
important to yourself.
And you know,
people say,
oh,
making the world a better place to live
or come on rush,
hurry.
Right?
But what is,
what is your world,
Dave?
What is my world?
It's the places you go,
the people you meet and the things that
you do.
And if in doing these three things,
you have solved the problem and made it
a better place,
then you've made a world a better place.
But you've done it by focusing on things
that are important to you.
So it's interesting you're talking about
all these things through the business
lens,
but business,
what you're talking about is what you
said before,
which is,
which is happiness.
Yes,
absolutely.
And in fact,
on that point.
So what does success look like?
To me it is the ability to say I love
what I do and I'm good at it because
that's the word.
Choose spiral that enables self esteem.
And when you have self esteem because
you're good at something,
you want to invest in it to become even
better at it.
It's pretty cool waking up with that,
with that feeling.
So that was number two.
What does success look like?
You mentioned all of them already,
but I just want to read a little bit.
So what is your value proposition?
So notice that,
uh,
the answer to the question,
what does success look like?
Takes an inward perspective,
what do I love?
And then what are my abilities that will
help get me to where I love and what I'm
good at?
What is my value proposition is still
looking at your abilities,
but now the yard stick is how is it
creating value to you?
So can you say,
I love enterprise and innovation,
right?
I love what I do.
I think I'm,
I'm pretty good at it.
Are pretty good.
I come up every morning with a spring in
my step.
But why would that cause you to want to
use,
you know,
ask Rajshree to join you this morning as
opposed to multiple other people that
you do.
So what's my value proposition to you?
What benefit do I offer you?
The features that are unique to me that
is the focus on value proposition and
it's obvious because we have the
evidence right here because of all the
people that I talked to that weekend.
Uh,
you were one of,
I think two people who I said to the
learn liberty guys,
we're going to get her up the show.
You came up to me after we had a great
conversation about all of this stuff and
they go and then finally,
uh,
with,
who should I train?
That is the one thing that stumps a lot
of people and uh,
goes back to the what is my purpose,
making the world a better place to live
by doing something important to me,
right?
So providing benefit to someone else,
but making sure that I'm benefiting and
I'm doing something I love to the answer
to what does success look like is really
getting to what you love doing,
which is about you.
The answer to your value proposition is
providing benefit to someone else,
right?
Making the world a better place to live,
with whom do you trade is bringing those
two together.
So you and I are trading right now.
We may not be exchanging any dollars,
but there's a trade going on out here
and that relates to your abilities and
your aspirations and my abilities and my
aspirations and were combined together
with a common objective.
So the alignment of your aspirations in
my abilities are what's going to
determine our actions.
And in doing so,
I get to do what I love doing.
I also you a benefit.
So do you and its amendment trade.
Well,
I got to do what I love doing here.
I feel that we,
I think we did almost everything.
Is there anything that we possibly
missed?
This was,
this was truly a pleasure because this
was exactly what I've tried to do in my
life and with this show and everything
else,
and you're,
you just exude exactly what you're
talking about,
which is a joy to see.
Yes.
And in fact,
that's exactly why I want to trade with
you.
I love that,
right?
Because you exude the same positive can
do sense of life and I would rather have
people around me that have that same
spirit make me better,
make me more energized than people that
either I bring down or they bring down,
uh,
you know,
do they bring me.
Can we do a live event together?
Can we do something I knew,
Marilyn,
we're going to make something happen.
Sounds good.
This was,
this was truly a pleasure.
I'm glad it happened.
After a couple of months.
And for more on Rajshree,
you can check out her website,
which we've linked to write down below.